[Music]
hey everyone good afternoon thank you
for joining us during your your lunch
or hopefully your skipping lunch to
check us out here first time I've
presented in a movie theater
too bad we're not doing like Avengers in
game that would be a pretty cool session
but we're here to actually talk about a
partnership between sa P Google and
Intel specifically around a technology
called Intel obtain DC persistent memory
I'm Jack Vargas I'm one of the product
managers on at Intel working on this
technology soon in the next couple
sessions you'll I'll be joined by my
friends Tim Andres and Rohit so to give
you an overview about why we're here and
what we're talking about I'll spin the
first section talking a bit about the
history of this journey what this
technology is about why we're even doing
it then Tim will come up talk about si P
Hana
and then Andreas and Rohit will join us
for the final session we plan to have a
couple minutes for Q&A I know it's kind
of dark but there are some mics up here
on this second row here so if you have
any questions just head on down and
we'll take your questions toward the end
of it all right
so first I want to talk about the this
journey that Intel's been on we've been
working on this technology for the past
10 years and really the last six of that
has been in deep engineering
collaboration with sa P specifically
optimizing s to be Hana to take
advantage of this new technology
category called persistent memory now in
the last couple years have been really
exciting for the partners listed up here
so actually two years ago sa P was the
very first company to demo persistent
memory live at sa P sapphire and then
this past fall during an Intel event we
gave Bart Santo Santo who Santo sorry
who is a VP at Google cloud the very
first production dim of this Intel
obtain DC persistent memory and that
kind of started a slew of activities
working with sa P Google partners to
really start prototyping and doing pocs
around this technology and then actually
just a week ago until officially
launched this Intel obtained DC
persistent memory a general availability
along with our second generation of
Gyan scalable processor now why why is
Intel why are these companies kind of
rallying behind this technology you know
what what's the big deal what what's
going on and it really has to get do
with with data so in the the short now
six years in in 2025 for expect to
generate a hundred and seventy-five
zettabytes of data compared to 33
zettabytes generated in the last year
you know current technologies aren't
really equipped to make that data useful
to the industry's your customers your
your partners so let's explore you know
kind of why that is to give you a
fundamental knowledge of why this
technology is going to change computer
architecture as we know it so here's
kind of a classical pyramid diagram of
current technologies when it comes to
memory and storage now you may notice
there are big gaps between these and the
realm of computer architectures these
are oceans away so at the very top we
have memory which currently the mainstay
is DRAM memory so this is tiny
capacities compared to what you can see
in solid-state devices it can be
relatively expensive but it's really
fast we actually measure latency in
nanoseconds within this realm now we
cross the gap and we enter the storage
realm which currently the the two main
technologies are flash NAND SSDs and
then as well as spinning magnetic disks
like hard drives or even tape typically
latency measured in these are within the
realm of microseconds so again a
magnitude different than what we can
have with a memory though in the storage
realm they they have higher capacities
they're fairly affordable for the
gigabyte per cost but again they're
they're a magnitude different in in
performance so this bottleneck has
actually been in computer architecture
for quite some time we're actually
software has really just worked around
this by really optimizing code to make
it advantage of it now how how we're
changing this equation is by this new
technology called Intel obtain DC
persistent memory really the first
mainstream persistent memory technology
that's coming to the marketplace so this
is big a four
as well as the data on it can be
persistent even after a server reboot a
power loss etc we're coming to market
with a 128 256 and 512 and actually my
pocket I have one of our 512 capacities
right here so with these you can have a
total of 6 of these on a
second-generation Xeon processor
platform and you pair those with a dram
so on one socket 6 of these on a
standard 2 socket server you kind of up
to 12 so if you take the 512 multiply
that by 12 you have a total of 6
terabytes of persistent memory available
on your your platform now also I will
mention that since now in the memory
realm data is at rest
security is quite important so these
actually come in with standard hardware
encryption all right now how I'm going
to give just a quick download of how we
actually use this technology
so there are specifically two operating
modes so think of one as being a
persistent memory and I'll get into
details of how you can use that and the
other one is actually kind of our easy
way to take advantage of that large
memory footprint but without the
persistency and we call that memory mode
so let me talk about app direct mode so
an app direct mode this technology is
transparent to your operating system
your users your application and smart is
vs independent software vendors like s
ap who understand their data structures
very well we'll put the data structures
which make the most sense in the medium
that they have available so for those
data structures that make the most sense
in DRAM where you need that high
bandwidth they can pit the data
structure there but if you could utilize
maybe a lot of persistent memory and
take advantage of it being persistent if
I had to do a server patch or something
it's able to come up quickly versus
previous generations I will make note
with app direct we there is that usage
but there's actually a second usage
where you can actually use standard
storage api's so instead if you wanted
to just use standard block IO or
actually boot from the the the dims
itself we do support that now with
memory mode how this is utilized is
basically the platform is going to
consume the DRAM in your system to act
as a really fast right
back cache so from applications
standpoint that six terabytes I
mentioned before it'll just see that six
terabyte and won't see the the DRAM
behind that acting as a cache so with
this again this is a volatile usage and
really this is to be out of the box if
you want to have six terabytes available
of volatile memory this is the route to
go now hopefully that's a quick 101 of
Intel opt in DC persistent memory I'll
turn over to my friend Tim now to talk
about sa P Hana
so I'm Tim Allen I'm on the SP account
team so SP czar is the first major or
DBMS to support Intel op team persistent
memory in app track mode now today it's
kind of fitting my name is Tim Allen I
used to do a little acting we're in a
movie theater so I just wanted to just
made me think about my prior life so
when we think of interrupting DC
persistent memory this kind of fills in
the blanks that Jack was talking about
as you can see there's this new layer
persistent memory that kind of touches
the gap between storage and memory and
like I said SCP we've been working on it
for several years it finally launched
last week so so when you look at Intel
out in DC persistent memory I look at
Hana 2.3 Hana 2.3 was released prior to
sapphire last year it was the first
major database to put to support
persistent memory and now we have some
specifics no Andreas I'm not going to
talk about 2.4 but obviously we know
that's eminently coming you know soon
but okay so it's imminent it was
released last Friday so this flow could
be updated but it's still the same as I
like to think of it s AP has been has
supported persistent memory for a long
time even before the product released
now a couple of things to pull off this
foil is with persistent memory and this
is just compared to the last generation
they were the first generation of Intel
Xeon Platinum processor
for transactions it supports up to 3x
more capacity and for analytics it
supports up to 6x so I'll get into
specifics of how that works here now
historically at Intel we've worked with
sa P fur for over a decade on Hana each
generation we've added either features
new features in the xeon processor level
as an example about three or four years
ago we added a feature called TSX which
sped up to write by transactions by
almost five hundred percent and that was
the e7 v3 platform and fast word this
year released the second generation of
the Intel Xeon Platinum processor and
now we support persistent memory at the
processor level and so this kind of
gives you a brief summary now I know
there's not a one-to-one mapping with
GCP but at least it tells you at the
processor level historically for
transactions what were some limitations
so if we look back to the e 7 v4 we
supported up to 3 terabytes per
processor with the last generation of
the processor we spread up everything
about about 60% if you look at some of
the SCP BW for Hana benchmarks however
we took half of the processor or Isis 8
we took half of the Dan slots away so
that's why you see a went down from 3
terabytes to 1.5 well at this one you
still have the same amount of DIMM slots
as you did as the first generation of
Intel Xeon Platinum processor but now we
support up to four point five terabytes
per processor and if you think about
that that's pretty powerful so what does
that say on a four socket configuration
you can actually have 18 terabytes okay
so when I think of our data management
challenges obviously we know our data
always grows there's always a consistent
cost of well how do we manage it what's
our operational budget and then how can
we get answers and solve problems
quicker for our customers so decrease
time to value now and I think of
persistent memory I think
solves kind of this heatmap issue so
traditionally and Jack referred to this
previously you just had three tears yet
your do you a unclear in memory and then
four things now I have to admit another
previous life I used to be a DBA
and even within memory you don't store
everything and then memory database so
like your your data that's like your
quarterly your monthly reports you
likely will put that in warm data which
is the orange represented here and the
blue data is for for like your big data
stuff that you'd store like in cloud era
or something similar
now with persistent memory and this
larger capacity what you see is kind of
a emerging or a new zone the second to
the left there the Intel opting DC
persistent memory zone which has both
the capacity to store warm and and hot
data now when I think about this what a
life I think about other the database
layer specifically the main memory or
about ninety-five percent of your data
can now be stored in persistent memory
this also applies to potential new
features that were added in Hana 2.3
like extension notes so that gives you
an opportunity to put persistent memory
both in the hot and the warm data tiers
now when I also think about persistent
memory it's we are driving the cost down
of compute now on Hana when I think of a
historical on-premise scenario I'm
hearing customers just last year were
buying new systems and they're telling
me the but about 60% of the cost of that
system was just the memory cost so we're
going to drive down that cost with the
dims that we just released and there's
going to be better opportunities for
business continuity and this is a good
place where GCP plays it I'm hearing
some customers that kind of a hybrid
scenario where there will still host
locally in their data center but they're
going to use replication to do disaster
recovery
for instance to the Google cloud so
that's something think about in your
scenario and I already talked a little
bit about increased memory capacity
okay so when we delve a little deeper
we're also seeing with this increased
capacity and an opportunity not just for
from a lower dim price perspective or
price for gigabyte there's opportunities
to consolidate multiple instances Intel
IT in particular we're actually in the
process of consolidating both our ECC
and our and another on a native instance
into one so look for solutions are you
discussing that in detail here in the
next couple weeks leading up to sapphire
[Music]
so the other thing I like to think about
and I alluded to this earlier I call
this the layer cake but as you can see
that this is a piece of cake that's
fallen on its side and now we have
persist the area in green is where
persistent memory falls into place
okay that is your main data stores now
as Jack said - previously you're still
going to need some DRAM but the vast
majority of the Hana database in orange
is where your main memory is going to be
stored so it's gonna vary per customer
but rough estimates I'm hearing is
between 95 96 percent of your data will
now be in persistent memory and that's
going to improve your loading reloading
of the database at startup it's going to
improve the the time the data load of
that significantly it's going to go from
potentially up to an hour 2 minutes the
last thing I want to talk about it is
business continuity now there's lots of
things when you think of business
continuity the first thing I think of
first and foremost is is backup as you
can see this actually shows an
opportunity to introduce persistent
memory into your existing environment
where you still have some some older
systems that just have all DRM and now
you can do a rope
patient scenario where you can use
persistent memory on the right with the
orange the darker orange with some DRAM
because you now have a bigger footprint
this can also be used for for backup
this can be used for disaster recovery
at a disparate look at a different
location it could be used it on the
Google Google cloud as an example and
the last one is a new use case with
extension nodes so extension of nodes
was a new feature that was added in Hana
2.3 it does not replace dynamic tearing
that still exists but it's a nuke
feature that allows you to do to place
your warm data into persistent memory
and then has the scaling factor of 8 to
1 in other words you can have 8 times as
much persistent memory in the dark
orange as you have as you have with DRAM
so look look - SVP to get more details
on how to implement that the other thing
nice with extension nodes is it gives
you the full Hana instance for your
warned data and then that will give you
full access to all the Appel libraries
to do analytics but that I'll turn it
over to Andreas thanks a lot Tim so
microphone is working
my name is I'm flew all the way from
Battle of Germany so I'm representing
SVP in this long-standing cooperation
cooperation between the three companies
I'm the product manager for persistent
memory in STP HANA and before I get
started and telling you a little bit
more about how Hana is actually using it
and what it means for honor let's
briefly wrap up what we just heard so we
had check in the very beginning
introducing the technology itself of
Intel obtain T persistent memory this
new pretty nice pretty exciting software
technology hardware technology and we
had Tim speaking about SVP Hana and a
couple of use cases that we see how Hana
can make use of that so but what does
that actually mean for ACP Hana info
ASAP Hana on GCP
so this is a pretty packed light I have
to admit that but it actually gives a
pretty good outline of the use cases
that we see in the benefits so basically
the main benefit being you can actually
process more data in real time so at a
basically the same performance as if it
was in real time in DRAM the TCO is
supposed to be much much more well
better for you and for companies so it's
cheaper than traditional D Ram and the
yeah one aspect that we haven't really
touched so far is the improved business
continuity so the main differences
between persistent memory and drm is not
just size and cost but it's also that it
is persistent so it means that it
doesn't lose the data when you start
down the server or the database which is
something that well at some point you
just have to do if you need to do
maintenance so for applying a database
upgrade or an operating system upgrade
or just to yeah
and buy so you can actually imagine what
it means for an in-memory database like
Hana
so all the data is kept in main memory
at all times to be able to process it
and to process it with with the speed
and the performance that you actually
expect and that Hana is promising but it
also means that if you shut down the
database all the derailment data gets
de-allocated giving back to the
operating system and when database is
coming back up the database stp Hana
needs to reload that from a persistent
layer which is in the case of SAP HANA
is just simple storage now as a
peace-offering
or positioning Hana in a big data
environment so for large amounts of data
in the terabyte scale and if you imagine
so no matter how fast the storage
actually is it takes some time so if you
need to load six terabyte of data into
from from like an SSD even if it's a
very fast SSD
into main memory this can take
considerable amount of time so what we
were able to achieve in this area is an
improvement by a factor of 12.5 so just
pay
Tunnel epoch sample that we did before
Steph fire last year so we were able to
reduce the start-up time including the
data loading phase from 15 minutes to
just 4 minutes so just means your
database is basically gonna be back much
faster after maintenance phase then it
was before and of course a zip is also
very proud that we want a long-standing
collaboration so that we actually able
to announce that we are the first major
database that is fully supporting that
we touched briefly the two operating
modes of persistent memory before so
memory mode inept direct memory mode is
basically the yeah you can you can run
every application in memory mode but you
actually take full advantage of the
technology including the persistence the
aspects that takes the app direct mode
and this is also so we spend significant
effort in our engineering department to
actually enable a CP HANA for that
technology and we got great assistance
from Intel on that by the way yes so
basically summarizing that again so you
get reduced TCO and four times increase
intensity so from 128 to 512 gigabyte
these are the ones that are available
right now and you can also you have to
put a potential to simplify your
landscape so these we have seen a couple
of examples before um so you because we
can make use of that capacity to well
put in more data or just install two
databases on one physical server or on
one the astrovan generals of can of
course also be virtualized this in some
cases allows you to actually avoid a
scale out scenario so a scenario where
you logically combine two servers to one
I mean it's basically two servers so you
also in terms of operating that it
becomes more complex and you can which
is also a pretty good value proposition
is the aspect of data tearing so
persistent memory is not per se a data
tearing technology
so that's not how a disposition and it
also would not be fair to call it that
because the performance is actually not
for warm data so you don't have any
performance difference if you keep data
there but it certainly has an influence
on how you do data tearing or whether
you have to do data tearing and in the
first place because if let's assume you
have like 50% of your database size is
warm data data that you could actually
move somewhere else
by using just dims that out twice twice
as large we can just keep that in your
heart here you have to same performance
for the hot data and what I think is
even more important you don't need to to
go through that whole project of
actually identifying what data is warm
and you don't need to move the data you
can just leave it as it is it is a
simple formal operations perspective and
you also basically might prevent you or
you don't need to add an additional
system like dynamic tearing or a second
like another external code data tear
yeah I explained about the business
continuity aspect already so it is 12.5
times improvement in restart times or
like data loading times at startup this
is well this lab example we have
actually proved that many times during
the last year so we've done a couple
theories and with customers so real I'm
real live customer systems and sometimes
we've even seen much higher factors so
up to effect 21 depends a little bit on
the actual size of the database so
because well the larger your system is
the more time you save basically by not
having to load that data and the higher
also the vector becomes so on Google
Cloud so good cloud has also been a very
well collaborated collaborative partner
for that 4 inch and SVP in the last year
and today Google cloud is actually the
first public cloud provider to offer a
virtual machines that use persistent
memory
so the instances that TCP is offering
its a 96 VC po7 terabyte virtual machine
so 7 terabyte combined DRM and
persistent memory of which 80% is
actually obtained so persistent memory a
factor of 1 to 4 and this basically
brings to a higher overall capacity at a
lower cost or at the same cost as a
smaller one then you should just compare
that to to a system with just erm ok so
I've to put a couple more numbers behind
that that that promised as we make that
we make in terms of restart time and to
also show you how how this actually
works so Hana is designed and what what
the startup time is actually composed of
so there are two components that are
pretty stable it's like the Hana
shutdown and Hana startup this is just
to basically load the binaries and to
shut down the software so this stays
pretty much the same no matter what what
data size you have and also whether you
steer more persistent memories that
there's not too much that you can
actually improve there but what is what
is really really important is the time
that it takes you until your data base
is back for normal operations so the
time until you can use your data base in
the same way and with the same
performance as you could before you shut
down the database and this is yeah it is
this these bars on a very right one so
with persistent memory in this case it
took 23 seconds compared to 280 which
roughly corresponds to that vector that
we've seen before
and this difference will of course
increase the larger your systems get so
if you have a I mean Hana is available
in sizes up to 24 terabyte for a single
instance so you can expect even large
improvements if you if you're actually
running a system in that size
so this light is actually very similar
from what it tries to tell so how do you
operate on time of a typical SVP system
actually looks like so there's typically
a phase where you prepare your downtime
in the very beginning so you prepare the
application to actually make it ready
and to tell it yet the database is going
to be shut down takes a couple minutes
so that's actually not too long and then
there's in this slide there's a pretty
pretty large downtime of 45 minutes so
this is actually the maintenance task
that you that you need to to execute on
your database the duration of Ted of
course varies so 45 minutes is also
pretty regular already pretty large one
so like an operating system upgrade or a
database upgrade it's also a time that
you you cannot really avoid so this is
just what it takes to get ready and then
the interesting part is when you start
to host again so you see on the like the
upper one the upper bar shows persistent
memory obtained where after just like
four minutes after you instantiate or
basically we instantiate the database it
is back with the same performance as it
was before if you compared it to how it
looks with DRM um in this case so the
data when it's loaded is of course
prioritized so the most important data
is loaded first so that your system can
go back as fast as possible so for 34
minutes it takes in this case to get to
two and a half terabyte ready with the
most important tables so that your
system can can go back to actually sort
of your queries but the time it takes
for the full five terabyte is even
longer so in this case almost an hour so
you can imagine what what that actually
means for your for your system and with
this I'd like to hand over to Rohit who
will tell a little bit more about the
roadmap Thank You Andres
so here just to give you guys a quick
overview of Google's journey on
providing system sizes Google has been
true to providing all the systems as
virtual machines so far so you'll see on
the roadmap when we started off back in
2017 was the first Hana system that was
two hundred and eight gig of memory and
we have come a long way now if you look
at q4 2018 we're able to release up to a
4 terabyte single node machine that's
available and now with the partnership
from sa PE and Intel and Google now
we're able to release the first 7
terabyte system that's running on obtain
memory and further down the road map
you'll see a couple of months down the
road we will be releasing the six
terabyte and the 12 terabyte again
single node virtual machines that will
be available to run on a single node
scale-up mode and then around the end of
the year we will be releasing the 18
terabyte VM again so to conclude today
thanks to Intel and s ap to introduce
you folks to the Intel obtain DC memory
persistent memory based Hana systems
that will be available in Google Cloud
we have information available for their
information you can always contact Tim
Andreas and Zak for further questions
[Music]